كيف يجب أن يتم وضع المستثمرين الأذكياء في
الوقت الحالي ،
فأنا أحب هذا السؤال ، هذا هو سؤالي المفضل
لأنني أعتقد أنه يمكنك فعل
الكثير الآن ، رقم واحد يمكنك شراء
السندات ، فهناك الكثير من
السندات الجذابة للغاية ذات العوائد الجذابة للغاية إذا
كان لديك نقود  في البنك الذي يمتلك
سندات خزانة لمدة عامين ، فقط السندات البلدية التي
تمتلك ائتمانًا عالي الجودة أمر
منطقي جدًا في الوقت الحالي في المرتبة الثانية من بين جميع
الأسهم الدفاعية في السوق.
تستحق الأسهم امتلاكها ، وبعد ذلك مع انخفاض السوق
وترى أنك تعلم أنك
ترى الانتعاش في العام المقبل
بمجرد أن نعلم أنه سيكون
هناك انخفاض ، فهناك الكثير من الأشياء التي يمكن شراؤها
بما في ذلك أسهم التكنولوجيا ، بعضها
أصغر و  أه تعلم أن الشركات
الصغيرة والصناعية ستبدو جيدة
في بداية العام ولكن الآن
تريد أن تضع موقفًا دفاعيًا ولكنك
لا تريد أن تجرب  يا وقت هذا السوق
لأننا لا نعرف كل توقيت
كل عوامل الأخبار التي
نواجهها الآن